the ukrainians are continuing with their
tactic to stretch Russian defenses as
far as they can and so what we can see
this week is they've begun to open up
the offensive in different places north
and south of bakmut north of baton
Butcher solidar and south of back motor
to ivanisk they're they're doing some
important uh offenses around barinka at
uh krasner Rifka and at vulador very
important strategically there is quite a
good good set of evidence that uh that
rivner pill has been taken by the
ukrainians and that would be quite
important if they've got that far down
the Russians seem to acknowledge that
they have lost reason appeal this is one
of the big fronts at oracleeve tours top
Mac this is really tough for the
ukrainians but they're continuing to
push there and one of the most important
interesting developments is that we now
have confirmation that they have crossed
the nipple River in the hersan region
and are fighting at oleski and the
Russians have counter-attacked the
dolesky we're not sure how they've got
on we don't think they've gone on too
well but the fact that they've
counter-attacked shows that the
ukrainians have actually created the
Bridgehead on this side of the river the
purpose of that is to try to persuade
the Russians to take more troops away
from this front which is very important
to have to do something about that the
Russians may or may not choose to do
that they've certainly committed some
troops to it whether they'll commit
enough rather remains to be seen
and all this is going on on the
background of the soap opera which is
now the pregosian uh Rebellion this
armed Rebellion pregosian uh Putin's
caterer the man who was very close to
Putin going back to their old Petersburg
days and they were friends they were
directly connected to each other and if
we look at the way in which they relate
to the the structure of decision making
in uh in the whole Ukraine uh War it's
very curious because pragosian has a
direct line into Putin and he relied on
that he thought the Putin was protecting
him and he certainly used it and he
overstepped the line increasingly in the
last couple of months but very much so
in the last week but formally
the system goes from Putin to the
defense minister shogu to the chief of
the combined Forces Group who's in
charge of what's going on in Ukraine
which is grazimov and this man
he's very important because he was very
close to pregozin it was expected that
sorovicin might come out in favor of
pragosian he didn't but keep your eye on
him this isn't so popular which will
keep on going and like many soap operas
it will probably have some twists and
turns yet